you know I've noticed that anyone who
gets cancelled for a joke in trouble for
a joke uh if they're funny it
accelerates their career a h hundredfold
this happened to Shane Gillis yeah with
Saturday Night Live yeah and you look at
that mistake you know Shane Gillis got
seen you know I'm a partner in a in a
festival called JFL oh yeah I'm one of
the so that's where he got seen at new
faces and hired for yeah Saturday Night
Live yeah but now he's bigger than
Saturday Night Live would have ever made
him exactly in fact he might be bigger
than Saturday Night Live period he might
have more people watching him and paying
him and and seeing him live and
everything then the entire Show's cast I
don't think there's anybody there I
think if you combine the entire cast and
looked at their ticket sales I don't
think they are anywhere near what he's
doing I mean he's an absolute monster
and more importantly he's one of the
best so if you try to if they try same
thing happened with Ari shaffir another
great comedian um who just put out one
of the best our specials uh had on in a
in like a decade je yep it's amazing
yeah it is amazing it's so brilliant and
so smart and um these people are
thriving including myself if if it's not
right if it's for a joke you're only
going to help the person and during that
the few days like I said yeah I was
stressed then because I didn't see it so
clearly but meanwhile those guys are all
calling me Shane's calling me saying
don't apologize it's going to be all
right AR's calling me going whatever you
do don't apologize everything's going to
be fine and all these other people are
calling me going are you going to
apologize are you going to make a video
are you going to write a statement are
you going to have your agent write a
statement are you going to make a video
where you explain what happened are you
going to write a thing where you explain
what happened and I'm taking in all this
information from all these different
people and I mean a lot of them aren't
Ari and Shane and by the way Ari and
Shane really blew up kind of after my
thing they were getting bigger but their
wild success hadn't happened yet but
what they kept saying is what stuck with
me which is say nothing if you explain
what happened then what the hell are we
talking about here you're explaining a
joke and if you apologize for a joke
which was the farthest which was the
last thing that I wanted to do and each
one of my wildly successful friends that
were recommending that I was listening
to them I was taking in the information
I wasn't saying no I'm not going to do
that but I was saying you know I was
asking questions and trying to figure it
out but it was never an option I mean as
corny as it sounds but like apologizing
for a joke in my world I think that
would have canceled me to my base to the
people that watch kill Tony to that have
seen me do a billion worse things on
Mondays and everyone laughs and we move
on 7 seconds later there's another joke
so what you offended about something
back then you want to pause and Rewind
and watch it
again